the Joe Rogan experience I'm not gonna
lie man I'm telling you of all the
people I've trained with I think overall
when you put the entirety of the mixed
martial arts together
Mozilla might be the best real like he
liked his boxing is some of the best in
the sport of mixed martial arts he he's
not a kickboxer but he's confident and
comfortable with all the kicks wrestling
his wrestling is way beyond a guy who
never wrestled like you know it's like
he's like Division one level you know at
the very least and then his jiu-jitsu
people sleep on his jiu-jitsu madmaz
Badal isn't the JIT on the ground the
first day I went into American talked
and we had fought each other before and
I figured not this guy's horrible on the
ground we just go but like I was like I
was surprised and this was like 12 years
ago
10 years ago you know yeah and he's day
in day out he's a worker like he's
constantly working on his crap he's
constantly working to get better um Ben
Askren you know he's got the ground he's
you know he's got the wrestling but but
Maz Woodall defensive wrestling is
asking to be able to you know Maul him
like he's done to everybody else and
he's got to close that distance he's got
it close
I mean and on the feet Maz Woodall has a
giant advantage just giant footwork yeah
great hands but oscar has this crazy way
of getting a hold of people even Robbie
even after Robbie was blasting his
brains into another dimension he still
got up and was grabbing Robbie it's like
he has this ability to grab people and
hold onto people like if he watches the
Douglas Lima fight or the korish Cobb
fight in in Bellator like Jesus Christ
like he he bragged all's people it's
weird any hole yeah he's hard to get
away from mm-hmm very hard from I
remember when I first met Ben he um I
watched he went to this torn he used to
do tournaments and in college just to
get more pins so you could have like the
pin record so he got the pin record
forearm from Missouri for the University
of Missouri used to but he would also
with other high level wrestlers he would
just like let people take him now Jay or
I'd let people in on his legs so he can
get into these scrambles
funk stuff that he does yeah it's her he
has Dean Thomas one time he's wrestling
on that same trip he's wrestling with
Dean and he just stopped everything like
do you not a sprawl like like like Dean
and didn't even know what a sprawl was
cuz his wrestling is so good he just
touched he was touching us and we've
fallen over I mean wow
his wrestling is that good well it makes
it even more impressive with Jordan
Burroughs to do him when Jordan
Burroughs didn't have that wrestling
rush like there's levels and he said it
afterwards you put it on Instagram
there's levels to this and there is
because he just ran him over right
through him power doesn't isn't it crazy
just when you think about that a guy
who's the elite of the elite in
wrestling is so much better than the
elite of the elite of in wrestling and
MMA yeah this is so much better but
would he have still been able to do that
the same way if Ben was only wrestling
got some big it's hard to say because
Jordans so good yeah he's so dominant
it's hard to say are you talking about
what a two-time Olympic champion yeah it
was unbelievably explosive - any work
you ever seen his workouts all plyos
drills explosive drills and he's just
all about closing that distance with
just ferocious energy boom as he crosses
that distance wing is not even there
goddamn teleports I was hoping he was
gonna get into MMA but it doesn't seem
like he wants to know I am honestly when
he was still in school so one of my
buddies Lynn OD'ing he was reaching out
this sound like my tyrant he was
reaching out to Division one wrestlers
for me to help me with my wrestling
after the job Stephenson fight because I
was like I can't wrestle alright and um
Jordan burrows was one of the guys he
reached out to and he was just not
interested in MMA at that point anyway
he was like I'm going to Olympics I'm
gonna wrestle he had no interest I don't
know where that stands now because the
sport is bigger there's more money in it
yeah but he's still having so much
success wrestling right and who knows
how much time if any he's put into
striking yeah but like that IQ of his as
far as wrestling that
lettuce isn't you know he's a hard
worker oh yeah it will apply if he
dedicates himself to it but if he hasn't
at all he's so far behind the eight-ball
like if he jumps in now with zero
striking you know how long would it take
before he gets to a comfortable level of
striking where he can hang in there
[Applause]